the gyro can experience the subject of
dolphins has been I mean was a huge bit
on my 2016 Netflix special about an
experience that I had when I was in
Hawaii high as [ __ ] on edibles and we
ran into this patch of wild dolphins and
they were playing with us they're
playing with us and we were yelling like
yeah and they would jump out of one and
do flips for you they were putting on a
show and I remember having this thought
like holy [ __ ] they're playing with us
these are these wild creatures and
they're having fun with us and then I
started doing all this research on
dolphins and dolphin communication I
became obsessed with dolphins because
there's one I mean I had I had been
fascinated by them before but I became
truly obsessed and this was this
experience was more than ten years ago
and since then I've just been
overwhelmed and and also massively
disheartened by just you know by films
like yours and by seeing SeaWorld and by
seeing what was going on in marine land
with my friend Phil and I've had him on
a bunch of times to talk about his
lawsuits I mean they have done
everything they can to try to silence
that guy and stop him from revealing all
the horrors to that place but slowly but
surely he's had a massive impact on that
places business to the point where
they're trying to just get him to shut
up and he won't he won't meaning he was
you mean he was on the inside he was a
trainer and all that stuff so for me to
be able to talk to someone like you it's
it's you know it's I love the fact that
we can get that out there well I
appreciate it you know I mean it's well
you know swimming with dolphins in the
wild there was a trigger to memory over
in ranga rao's with with our team and
there was three groups a resident
dolphins that so they were there hanging
out there all the time you get to
recognize them and we were playing with
them and the more you play with them the
more you can spin around the more you
can you know the more excited they get
yeah and they could only do it for so
long and I remember what's that we were
doing it we finally we were we had
scooters and we thought well the more if
so a dolphin looks at you and you can't
you
look like you're like in a wheelchair
get around pretty good but you know in
the water we just look like ya know
we're just pitiful
yeah then so they can only be
entertained so long which but the
scooters we figured we could engage him
a lot longer and then all of a sudden
this group just took off and there was
sort of that you're let down because you
have this you're high from the
experience of being with them in the
wild and they took off then we saw that
they were there's about an 18 foot long
hammerhead and they were taking turns
ramming it away from us yeah so it was
like not only were they playing with us
they were protecting us wow that must
been wild though seeing an 18 foot long
hammerhead hole yeah because they
disappeared into the blue and then we
could see them ramming this thing the
Dolphins were big you mean they're you
know not quite as long as this table but
they're you know they're probably three
to five hundred pounds and they're maybe
seven feet long and they look tiny next
to this short Wow
that's why that is wild yeah
occasionally you see they'll do drone
footage off of the coast of Malibu and
you see like a great white swimming
around there just a few hundred yards
away from surfers and my son does that
with drones he goes out of his kayak and
foot in films them my friend Peter Peter
Tia he say he's done a bunch of like
crazy endurance things and one of the
things he did he swam he swam to all the
islands in Hawaii and what to prepare
for this he had to do a lot of swimming
he lives in San Diego and swimming in
the coast out there and he was swimming
literally what do you see like a couple
days after that guy got bit in half oh
my god
yeah I think it was just different
scared you know he wasn't scared ever I
think my boys really freaked out but it
was it was within a few days of one of
the one of the guys who got bit in half
down in San Diego what did this happen
the San Diego incident I want to say it
was ten years ago somewhere in the
neighborhood of ten years ago and then
there was in one in Santa Barbara that
happened about four years ago four or
five years ago you know occasionally
they slip up I think a person's a seal
or something you know most of us the
time when I but I've
a dove a lot of sharks before the the
you could only usually only get them
around you if you're feeding them and
that feels so or horrible it's just so
unnatural I won't do it anymore
but weird right yeah it's just just it's
just not I couldn't be around it there's
some friends of mine that were feeding
it you know they're on a feed and I was
I was about I don't know 50 yards away
and I thought I just don't want to be
part of it and I was just filming on the
reef and these silver tips came over and
I don't know if they're excited by I was
had a camera with the strobes on it but
they just came and they were like
attacking me and I had a rebreather I
died with a rebreather so you can scream
so I started screaming as long as I
could through this thing but I was
pushing pushing them off and they were
like working together you could see it
was like pack you know like when we go
this way so he had a like I had these
these lights with these like octopus
with four lights on it and I could push
him away but then one of the the guys
that we had brought over a tuna head and
lured him away but they were just it was
because he that is because they were
excited by you know the the feeding over
there so I don't even want to be in the
water these days when people are feeding
sharks because it's no joke when you're
under the water that's not your you
Sally could just run to run up a tree no
place to go no where to go you feel
helpless and that's their natural
environment and that's what they're
there for
they're there to clean up you know
anything this week anything that's
[ __ ] up anything you know any seal it
get caught slipping there they're there
for population control I mean there's a
really powerful video off of the I'm
sure you've probably seen and off of
Fisherman's Wharf in San Francisco we're
a bunch of tourists are there a boom
this great white snatch is a seal right
in front of everybody
just just thunderous explosion of blood
and foam in the water and like whoa you
know a couple miles from where I live
yeah yeah I mean they're they're magic
that's a that's a sea beast I'm supposed
to let me just invited me today to go
out
and be with great way it's not diving
just uh just to watch just to watch
there's a crazy video from I think it
was the Cape somewhere around the Cape
Cod where there's like a 20-foot one
next to a boat and these guys were in
this boat and this this great white just
swims right up next to them and they
start [ __ ] screaming and freaking out
and it's enormous it's like 20 feet long
the only point I like if you don't feed
them they're usually fairly if you have
if you're feeding them or if you're a
spear hunting then they'll come near you
they're dangerous for spear hunters
right yeah
what is this record-breaking year for
sharks off Cape Cod yeah apparently
there's a lot of them out there now what
do you think that is that because of a
large number of marine mammals or or
drones we could actually see him now
[Applause]